so it's absolutely lovely to see you
here tonight for Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory and the seer so what
are you enjoying about tonight's
production oh well what I will enjoy I'm
quite sure is it all being revealed I
think it's a there's a lot of
anticipation involved in doing a
production like this and we're just so
happy to be here and I'm looking forward
to see I saw a little bits in the
rehearsal so now I'm really excited to
see it all come together how exciting is
it to have a director like Sam Mendes on
board
extremely extremely exciting I mean you
know you you you want to feel like this
is a really really great children's book
and you would have a really really
really great director and that sound now
what do you remember most about it from
your childhood Charlie the Chocolate
Factory what your favorite memories are
oh I think probably well chocolate for a
start was a favorite memory of childhood
and and then you know the characters
kind of came into our lives just because
we read the book and sometimes we talk
about them and sometimes we talk about
you know different aspects of people's
personalities and being like or not very
like these different characters good and
bad so yeah they would mean they they
were there you wish me your favorite
characters as a child and who did you
like in yourselves here in this story
well you know I always liked Grandpa Joe
I don't know why I mean maybe probably
because everyone everyone like ants
really want with my dad and I think
there are certain aspects of that but I
also seem a bit like grandpa Joe as well
so I love grandma
I mean obviously Charlie but
Grampa Joe and what kind of memories
will it bring back do you think Butte
and I to the show will you know one of
the memories I was telling my sister
today one of the memories is that I came
to the premiere of the first movie in
about 1971 or something like that 72 and
I remember that from here and that was
as a young kid so it's kind of wonderful
to be here tonight and actually see it
in its I think it's a story that really
will adapt well because it's so
theatrical and musical already and then
you have it brought to life by these
great talents it's gonna be magic why is
it still so popular sakes this is a
hugely popular with all generations
isn't it it is
I mean I think like a lot of my dad's
stories it does that it's their timeless
and their place lists in many ways so
that they appeal to all different kinds
of people across the spectrum so and
they have all of the bits of ingredients
that you you would think in in any great
story they've got you know the wicked in
the bad and the good and the underdog
but really really felt and they have
chocolate
you